and where we are as the Sun comes up
it's a little bit brighter and we can
start to make out some of the damage the
boats behind me heavy-duty nylon sails
have been torn like paper napkins and
there's no doubt that Doreen is getting
stronger as it makes its way toward the
coast with me now is the mayor of
Charleston John Tec Lindberg as you see
those pictures from our correspondent
there Jamie yuccas what are your biggest
concerns
well Tony thanks for being with us sorry
about then hospitable weather it should
be better by tomorrow by the way we're
concerned about the continued wind and
flooding potential for today thankfully
our citizens are staying put and I'm
asking for everybody to stay indoors
until this passes so they won't remain
safe you say thankfully your citizens
are staying put the governor said the
water is what kills and these people
along the coast eight hundred and thirty
thousand of them should get out of town
your people are staying does that
concern you well it's it's too late to
evacuate a number of folks left a number
of folks stayed but they're hunkered
down inside and we asked them to remain
that way for the rest of the day today
is durian Day in Charleston we're
starting to get reports about 80,000
people are without power we've got a
number of reports on trees down and
traffic lights out and that kind of
thing we have crews standing by to
recover all those things but we're also
waiting for the weather to get better
before we send them out Charleston is a
unique city it's got a triple threat
from durian here there's a storm surge
there's the wind there's the rain
there's also the high tide will concerns
you the most as we head toward high tide
around midnight tonight right well I was
really worried about last night's high
tide at 1:00 a.m. but it wasn't as bad
as had been predicted they're predicting
about a nine-foot tide for two o'clock
this afternoon so we're concerned about
that in conjunction with the rain but if
everybody just stays put we'll be safe
and then later today and tomorrow we'll
we'll be cleaning up and pumping out and
getting getting back in business
all right make Mayor John Tech Limburg
thank you very much glad to hear things
are are better than expected here in
Charleston at least so far but you're
keeping a close eye on it
all right thank you